[Music]
what have you seen as a correlation
between trauma and disease you know that
to my mind is the great question if I
were the head of NIH I would put all my
money in this one of the greatest
challenges with psychedelic research
I've seen it in my own environment of
two people who were terminally ill who
stopped being terminally ill after the
psyched experience reports of people who
give up their IBS for people who give up
their migraine headaches if I were a
young person beginning to run a
laboratory I'd say I'm going to see what
the core systems are that these agents
affect in the core organization of the
brain and the body's homeostasis that
may reset those things we're not
anywhere close to having a technology
for that can we make people healthier by
giving them a sense of in their safety
and that actually is based on a core
biological safety system taking care of
your health isn't always easy but it
sure should be simple I have been taking
ag1 for a couple of years now I take it
first thing in the morning on an empty
stomach which is how they recommend to
take it it has helped me feel the most
healthy that I've ever been that's
because ag1 delivers all of the vitamins
minerals prebiotics probiotics that I
need for my gut health which is where I
feel like I've had the most Improvement
my stomach feels flat not bloated ever I
can accept any food so much easier I
have more energy every day my skin looks
better there's a million things that I
feel like ag1 has helped with to make me
my healthiest self it's just one scoop
mixed in water every day and it makes me
feel the healthiest I've ever been if
there's one product I had to recommend
to elevate your health it's ag1 and
that's why I've partnered with them for
so long if you want to take ownership of
your health try ag1 and get a free
one-year supply of vitamin D3 plus K2
and get five free ag1 1 Travel packs
with your first purchase exclusively at
drink a1.com pretty intense that's drink
a1.com Prett intense check it out I'm
such a huge fan I read your book A
couple of years ago and uh just thought
it was just the most amazing thing so
that's why that's why I've asked for
this time with you thank you
great um so you said you've had a long
busy day I'm I'm curious what kind of
things are you working on right now well
I had a lengthy podcast about our
psychedelic studies and I saw a bunch of
my
patients and I'm finishing a book called
come to your sensus about working with
your body after trauma so you still see
patients yeah yeah the moment you stop
seeing patients you start getting
married to your
ideology you stop really facing reality
in some way yeah yeah is that like a
passion would you say that it's to keep
connected but you stop doing it and you
start believing that your own thoughts
are always true but as long as you see
complicated human beings you see that
different people need different things
keeps your mind open like there's a
tendency in the mental health field for
people to get ideological and religious
right and people say oh Freud and that
treatment and that treatment and people
get very passionate about a teacher and
a
modality and the real issue is what can
you do for this particular person and so
the ideology falls short and if you stop
seeing people you go with your ideology
about them with the needs of the people
you see yeah in my
training uh my big teacher said you have
only one teacher and that's your only
one textbook and that's your p patients
wow that's good advice that's very good
advice yeah yeah have there been any
fascinating patients that have come
through with very complex all of them
all the time yeah all the time yeah why
is it so
complicated why because we are
complicated
creatures and people keep wanting to
have simple answers and Simple Solutions
um um I see people gravitate to Simple
Solutions all the time and we are very
complex
creatures and uh we need to have
multiple perspectives to do things well
yeah this is an area of Fascination for
me psychology the body
treatments um I've done some of the ones
that you talk about and in fact Dove
much deeper into one of them based on
reading your book and really fell in
love with
EMDR EMDR I've also done psychedelic as
well and and somatic healing with um
sound and body movement and energy work
and and really tried to to tap into all
the different areas but I found EMDR to
be just I I can't tell you how many
people I've recommended it to and as
well as referenced your book for how
strong of an opinion you have about it
being a being a really good modality so
could you please explain it because I
have never been very good at explaining
it the EMD was really my first teacher
in that in our
culture we think that two things are
normal one of which is
yaking nobody ever said you should not
talk or you should not have a
relationship not that's s of a given um
and the other thing is there's a
tradition in Western World if you feel
back you take a
swig and always those
alcohol sometimes little dope but that's
part of our culture so it's perfectly
normal to say to people take this
drug um that's
acceptable and then first time I go to
China I think pretty miserable and I see
10,000 Chinese making these weird chiong
movements and they go into the park and
they go wow this is such a miserable
place people need to do these movements
in order to feel better so I saw that
another culture had a different way of
doing things but when I started to do
yoga here and and study yoga people said
oh god he has gone off to deep ends
because it didn't fit in with our
cultural prejudices right and then I was
involved in the truth Commission in
South Africa and I see people people
dance and sing
together if you start singing and
dancing together at the hospital people
think you you're gone crazy yeah in
other cultures that's perfectly
normal and so you get to see the
difference culture have different
solutions and the first time I get
exposed to
EMDR I think that is crazy and we at
Harvard and my colleagues start wiggling
their fingers in front of people's faces
and I say stop this [__] immediately we
try to be respectable people don't do
this stupid stuff and then
embarrassing embarrassing like we will
be kicked out if we continue to do crazy
stuff and that's what you do when you
get do unusual things and so um then I
saw some people really getting
remarkably better and so I did the first
and only an imh funded study on
EMDR and we had fantastic results and it
never really got integrated and
respected as a mainstream
treatment despite the fact that at least
60 100 thousands clinicians are
practicing around the
world the important Medical Center still
that's crazy and so what I learn from
EMDR is sometimes that's crazy things
work things that don't fit with your
cultural
prejudices so it liberating thing for me
to see that something that on the
service seemed absolutely bizarre had
such great results and that didn't have
to do with understanding inside or
changing people's chemistry yeah and
this that really opened my mind of wow
what else is there and how do we get to
be how do we deal with all this stuff
because it's not cognitive and it's to
some degree biological but not only
biological um and so uh EMD is a great
treatment to help to make particularly
memories of the past memories of the
past can you explain the mechanism how
it works well again you won't understand
the word of it we did a piece of
research after many years and what we
saw is that there's an increased
activity connectivity between the left
insula and the right temporal pral
Junction uh which is a way brain
circuitry gets activated that helps
people to realize that this belongs to
the Past the nul depress and sits in my
body really it really V
buers core neurological circuits in the
brain I looked at it like time travel
that's actually how it felt to me almost
as if I was able to go back in time and
revisit the experience with my maturity
with an observer perspective of the
event see it from the other person's
perspective of sometimes the other
person's family even and sometime like
one time I even had what felt like the
like Angels like and I was able to watch
some sort of orchestration of something
I needed to experience so I did I did it
many times more what you see in
psychedelics than EMDR but hey EMDR gave
you a great gift that's great I promise
I didn't pair the two together I've done
them but I have didn't pair them I'm
kind of curious what your thoughts are
on that and I uh on as far as time
travel goes and and and what that makes
you think of when I say that and and and
how we Define time travel and how we
think it's our biological body but it
sure feels like if if if we're not our
body and we are let's say our
Consciousness how is that not time
travel it's interesting how the word
time travel comes up a lot when people
talk about really having been healed
from trauma I hear it at least once a
week from oh wow okay and it would not
be a word that I would naturally use you
know I live in
a but have still solid leg in mainstream
Circle so when I start talking in
serious academic environments about time
travel they go he really has gone off
the
deepend but it comes up all the time
because indeed uh hypnosis
EMDR um ifs internal family system
therapy uh pics all allow you to revisit
the past and to come to ter with
something that happened a long time ago
and to really revisit yourself back then
but with the Consciousness that you have
right
now and so and in in all of these
methods on some level you get to see
what happened to that person back then
that they couldn't cope with it and so
they were overwhelmed by it they did the
best they did could and now you bring
your current resources into that
creature back then who you once were
yeah no but I'm really sort of hesitant
to say that because that sounds pretty
woooo doesn't it you've done
psychedelics though correct oh I'm very
seriously into psychedelics right now
right talk to me about
that well this past week our big article
came out uh called the effect of MDMA
on self experience in
PTSD and um I've been part of this very
large map study on MDMA and
PTSD and uh it was put together by Vic
doblin primarily Michael mid Hofer who
are real hero here against enormous
obstacles and so I been one of the 15
sides and uh we saw remarkable results
with MDMA actually larger than
just about anything we have
seen the research was pretty close to
what the MDMA research was also uh but I
was in charge of so-called secondary
data and the secondary data really
important data namely that what we saw
is that
MDMA quite uniquely can help people to
rearrange their relationship to
themselves and to feel compassion for
themselves to find words for themselves
to find understanding of themselves and
to soothe themselves and because they
gained that capacity to get perspective
from themselves they got better from
that PTSD so the big finding out there
in PTSD land is is a great treatment for
PTSD there's some other great great
treatment for PTSD but there is not a
great treatment for is for the residues
that very early life trauma leads leaves
inside of you if you get mistreated as a
small child you live in a legacy of
damage shame self-hatred self-loathing
is the word I like to use here ofing
that this has happened to me because I
was fundamentally a defective person and
that's Legacy of Early Childhood trauma
that people carry with themselves for
the rest of their lives and
clinicians all my colleagues who I love
and respect have have always been trying
to work on that issue of how do we help
people to feel like they are good people
and it wasn't their fault it happened to
it and somehow it is incredibly hard to
get it implanted in people even with the
and on
MDMA people got compassion for
themselves and were capable of
tolerating who they were were and
feeling this happened to a very
vulnerable little kid and if I'd been
there at that time knowing what I know
now I would done all kind of things but
really re aveng people's relationship to
themselves that to my mind is the great
message of psychedelics it changes your
relationship to your internal
self and some people say they have past
lives experiences and re experienc their
birth I'm not ready to go there right
but some people who are certainly
respect and admire talk about those
things yeah yeah are um have you re
researched s cyan iasa and some of the
other psychedelics as well the the the
MDMA study cost 64 $62
million so as somebody gives us another
$62 million we'll replicate that study
another AG it's not something you just
do right right A lot of people studying
these things but the
62 not so sure really no there's a lot
of review articles the real work of
putting a study together is unbelievably
expensive and complicated can you
explain what makes the real research
like what what qualifies what builds a
real research project and what makes it
so expensive sir for real research you
need to have control group so half
people get the real stuff and other
people get something else and so you
need to have a team that can provide the
other treatment and they need to train
people to have the the core treatment
then you need to videotape that you need
to make sure do the people do the right
thing and then you need to hire a team
of people who have no idea what
treatment have been get people have been
getting in order to evaluate what's
going on because you are supposed to be
blind right because Prejudice towards
let's say MDMA or EMDR how you tend to
Ser be judgmental in One Direction or
another and they need to hire a team of
statisticians and you need to pay all
kind of people along the way and
sometimes you have to sue some people
along the way uh commission to do things
and so uh but and then you have a team
of to administer people and and it's
it's very complex lots of layers what
about um as far as sort of the legality
of it on a federal level to be able to
actually proceed with these studies from
the outside looking in it seems as
though um a lot of these drugs or
medicines whatever you want to call it
have been very restricted not very
restricted they're illegal right
period restricted like no was the people
who who did his research were branded as
as
criminals is that how you see them too
no no no that's not no that's the fact
of our society right exactly T of
thousand people were put in jail for
using these substances right it's not
like a little bit inconvenience
no this is as a as a researcher and
that's why people like Rolen Griffith
who just died and his colleagues at
Hopkins are such admirable people
because they kept doing the research
despite the fact that they had
overwhelming opposition for example at
one point in my life I had Timothy Le's
office at Harvard and I was next to my
office next to leester grinspoon who was
once a a big name in the Psychedelic
field and so the people I knew were very
interested in psychedelics and knew
something about it none of us D to study
it and we studied prek instead because
you would get kicked out of Academia and
you would lose your respect of your
colleagues and so that's why I think big
doblin in particular and Michael mofer
and some other people are such
extraordinary people because they they
sued the FDA to do the stuff that they
did they fought their way through this
maze I've been recently connected with
Rick doblin and I'm excited to talk to
him at some point in time because he's
been obviously super instrumental in in
a lot of this if you were to put um if
you were to put a the next the next
illegal drug or or medication medicine
on the uh list for research which one
would you be the most interested well I
think they're all interested interesting
and what is really interesting to me is
that I still consider myself relative
newcomer uh to this field even though I
took LSD for the first time in
um we don't know what the differ effect
of the different drugs are uh and they
have different effects but nobody has
been able to articulate them yet and so
there's been research of IBO gain for
addictions there beene on MDMA for
addictions or C so right now say Iain is
the best for addictions maybe it is
maybe it isn't at Hopkins they have been
studying cment for depression and for
end of life issues so that's what it's
targeted to but is that the only thing
that does that we studied MDMA for PTSD
and now people say MDMA is a dark of
joice from PTSD I'm not sure if that's
true at all
maybe cocy may be as good or
better 5
Meo DMC is a very powerful substance
very intriguing
substance it does some things that the
other things don't do right now it's
still all word of mouth and who you
happen to know and where you spend your
weekends but where it's an underground
culture still by large you know yeah I
find um the plant medicine world to
be so effective because instead of
reading something and and and thinking
it you can even kind of know it even
like you're aware you know it but when
you go into those experiences it's such
a full body visceral experience that
again almost like EMDR you are actually
living it completely from head to toe
inside out and so you can't unknow that
it becomes part of your being so it's
extremely influential in the he it's in
a way an ineffable experience exactly I
can give you so Neuroscience explanation
what EMDR does and you'll be impressed
with it because you don't understand
what I'm
saying yeah but it doesn't really
explain it and you can say the memory
becomes something belong to the past and
it doesn't quite capture it either that
none of our language completely captures
what these substances do for
people makes me very much question what
the nature of this reality really is but
you know that that is a real question of
course and that's a question that um
actually you know it's interesting
because as you can see I'm not a young
kid anymore and so I grew up in the
world where everything was explained
with Freudian type Notions okay and in
terms of mental processes and I learned
P about how children develop minds and
stuff like that that learning about
about how people develop their mental
capacities develop has always gone
completely off the Wayside that culture
has disappeared the mind has disappeared
from
Psychiatry mental health got rebranded
Behavioral Health in other words you go
to a doctor not to be a pain in the ass
to other people but it's not about your
mind or your soul or your being and that
whole core issue that used to be Central
to field with William James and Pier J
and lot of people like
Android has has
disappeared and I think the psychedelics
hopefully will bring back an interest in
mental
processes but right now there is very
are very few ways of measuring these
things and almost no way of
communicating about it so we need to
really re ReDiscover the mind
right and the human mind actually which
has and hopefully Psychiatry will regain
its soul and not become an extension of
the drug companies
anymore exactly exactly which is why you
know the Curious question about from a
legal standpoint or federal level why
has some of this stuff been held back
and you know I get a little bit into the
conspiracy of its ability to heal people
which is yeah what people might want yep
these are
legitimate concerns and I see it
happening right now in psychedelics
again there's clearly a lot of people
are really realizing there's money in
themar Hills and now a lot of people
just rushing in to make money and I'm
not very optimistic about how that will
work out yeah from a ethic standpoint of
of of being a practitioner for these
medicines and how it goes take
shortcuts and like what you see already
in Academy clinics that people are
putting a little cubicle um these
substances bring up a lot of stuff in
people's minds lot of oftentimes very
painful memories and upsetting issues
right and if it's not done in a
theraputic context I think we may see
some very nasty side effects here yeah I
mean I would agree with that I've I've
also done ketamine too and um one time I
I had a nasal that was just uh ketamine
and oxytocin and I would get very bored
when I'd go in my hyperbaric chamber so
I would do that and do very little and
relax and I did just a tiny bit more and
it lasted like three times longer and I
thought I would get stuck there and and
and and and and this is and I would
consider myself to be a pretty
responsible person but but that is an
example of you know um how things can go
a little sideways and yeah that's that's
actually relatively minor you know
right for example first I had to take
MDMA for in my role principal
investigator and people had always um
asked me so Bessel you have seen so many
horrible traumas how has it affected you
and i' say you know if you have a good
marriage and some friends and good it's
not a big deal when I had my first MDMA
experience all my trauma test people
came to visit me for eight hours wow and
lied there for eight hours going oh [__]
oh I really felt nothing about the pain
I've been carrying of other people and I
thank God I was there with Michael mofer
and Annie and my wife who helped me as I
was feeling all the pain that I'd
absorbed over the years if I'd be by
myself I'm not sure if I've been able to
live with that you know I think this is
not an atypical experience we see this
right all the time in our MDMA study and
people come up with really horrendous
memories and and deep pain and that's an
important thing for them to get in touch
with but boy they better have some
really good support about themselves
because otherwise be overwhelming you
know yeah there was a fascinating Story
by Gabor mate have you met him
and yeah and about him going to with a
group to do I think it was Iowa
or at
least in that realm and and the the they
told him look you have too much negative
energy and they took him off and made
him do four days of ceremony on his own
to clear how much he had absorbed from
every anyone but it's this enters into
like a fascinating Dynamic of Being
Human which feels like you can't see
yourself it's so hard to see yourself
objectively and that we need other
people to bounce things off of or at
least gateways into other other ways of
thinking through these medicines or
through um EMDR and other processes so
that to me feels like the hardest part
is getting growing up as a kid you you
grow up and you don't know you have
certain programming you don't know
you've had traumas that then turn into
the way that you react and act in the
world
so why is it that we can't see ourselves
very clearly or maybe even at
all it's actually surprising degree to
which we do know ourselves because
that's not but we have brains for we
have brains to know each
other and so that's what you see when
you raise a kid I don't know if you have
kids but kids are completely antisocial
creatures when they come up and then
they slowly get cultivated to wake up at
the same time as other people to go to
school and put on their socks and to eat
at the same time as other people and the
brain is basically a social
brain when you work in places like um
many places in
Africa India
Yemen and you work with traumatic people
there you ask them what happened to you
they cannot talk about themselves they
can say my Village my people My Tribe
and people cannot differentiate
themselves from the people around them
and that is I think basically
how we were how we evolved as human
beings we primates who live in troops
and we did not EV evolve as individuals
and is sort of a side effect of American
culture that we actually that we're
unique people who are independent of our
environment language is really for me to
explain to you what you and I need to do
language is not to explain me to you and
and so many parts of the world
Psychotherapy are like in in Japan for
example or um in China Psychotherapy
would is not doesn't quite fit within
the culture all that
much because the culture there is very
much that you need to be fit into the
larger contact with Society you need to
learn to honor your betters and to fit
in that's sort of the main culture and
so America is quite different in that
regard that you need to I hear people
ask 14y olds what is your goal in life
14 years old you don't know what your
goal in life is
like you just need to go to school and
get good grades uh to get a candy bar
for lunch
like to play soccer later yeah that's
right
like so language is basically not about
self experience um as you certainly
discover in the Psychedelic world the
Psychedelic experiences that you have
are very difficult ult to describe in a
way
they're much larger than we are and they
help you to change your perceptions but
you know it's fascinating to see what
people say say about it but it never
quite captures the Ence
because uh it's not linguistic yeah yeah
does everyone have
trauma no no I think some people have
quite good Liv everybody has heartache
everybody God Ving
experiences uh all lives are
difficult even though on the surface
they may look nice we all have pain but
trauma in terms of being really messed
with by the people you count on being
assaulted threaten fre to life is not
Universal but it's interesting when PTSD
started to be studied what were the
countries that were the leading
countries in studying trauma Australia
Norway and the Netherlands there happen
to be three of the most civilized
countries in the world because in those
countries it was no longer normative to
be
traumatized
oh in so they're like they're standing
out more because they're very civilized
countries but you know in India you
there's so much misery That You Don't
See oldest person is miserable but 10%
of us are not
miserable right and so and but you saw
in China after the cultural revolution
like massive trauma they wouldn't talk
about trauma because everybody had too
much of it so it's is only once and
what's interesting to me actually is
that most people don't so I was on a
podcast with a very smart person not too
long ago and she said Dr Pand why do you
think there's so much more trauma today
than before and I went like did you take
any history classes like do you know
anything about history our lives
basically today are vastly more secure
than they have ever been
before I just read a book about
pandemics throughout history I mean
people got wiped out all the time
massively and the plague all these
diseases and now people think the the
the co is a big deal
compared to people used to go through
the co is a very minor deal
actually it's only once uh our
civilization managed to make a lot of
people feel relatively secure and life
predictable that we could think what
happens when that doesn't happen
interesting that's where the traa come
would you say that's a universal belief
that there is more trauma than ever is
she representing the collective well
that's completely misunderstanding
what's going on that's really not KN
anything about history
mhh we got to see that massive numbers
of people got wiped out all the time by
disease and and poverty and hunger and
Wars um I mean that's one thing that has
always intrigued me did any culture
figure it out and then I read books
about what pre- Colombian America was
look like the Incas the Mayas they were
messed up man they did terrible things
to each other people have always done
terrible things to each other throughout
history I don't think it's I dialogue
with d Lama and having a bit of a
provocative nature I asked him so your
Holiness I don't really like calling
people your Holiness but I did uh what
do you make of the fact that the three
worst genocides in the last 50 years
have been in Buddhist
countries how'd that go
he's answered me in tibetan so I don't
quite know what he said I question
whether what is inherent to this reality
that we live in and I wonder
if some level of that trauma or the
sadness or you know this negative
feeling is just kind of part of the
dualistic reality that we live in light
and dark good and bad happy sad yeah and
people have always thought it way and
people have always thought
tribally it's one of our curses and one
of benefits as we think in terms of
clusters and if you belong to my little
cluster then you and I will stick
together and we'll kill anybody who
doesn't belong to our
clust that's part of basic in the
military you they put you under extreme
stress where you're scared to death go
through basic training and by having
comment around you you get very attached
to the people who are going through the
same stress and now you're willing to
kill other people for the sake of your
comrades who you have got such great
hardship
with if you didn't have that hard basic
training people would stop killing each
other because you'd say why should I
kill you we're like a virus we're like
multiple viruses saying who's going to
win yeah and people have always always
done that everywhere every culture
the Buddhist Monastery in India every
year they came back two years ago he
says you know what they didn't by in the
monastery they built a wall right
through the middle of the monastery for
the monks who are adherence of the Dal
Lama and the
mon um something that affects everyone
to some
degree some large some smaller but uh is
sickness disease
in your research and experience what
have you seen as a correlation between
trauma and
disease you know that to my mind is the
great question I you know I like to say
from time to time if I were to had of Ni
I would have put all my money in this
and
with that to me is one of the greatest
challenges with psychedelic research is
that I've seen it in my own
environment of uh two people who were
terminally ill who stopped being
terminally ill after the psych
experience there's a lot anecdotal
reports of people who give up their IBS
for people who give up their um migraine
headaches
and if I were a young person R beginning
to run a laboratory i' say I'm going to
see what the
core systems are that these agents
affect in the core organization of the
brain and the body's hom stasis that may
reset those things we're not anywhere
close to uh having a technology for that
but that's the great challenge can we
make people healthier by giving them a
sense of inner safety and that actually
is based on a core biological safety
system H what about the uh the idea of
energy being stuck in the body and sort
of stagnant stuck energy and I think did
you say your book that you're writing
has to do with sound or
movement come to your senses come to
your
senses um see so I I have some good
friends who are not ashamed to use the
word allergy therapy uh David fste in
particular who I love and admire uh in
my world talking about allergies would
not be an acceptable way of phrasing
things right but that's all we are isn't
it well you can go there but then you
can you can be rang it in different ways
yeah y
yeah it's all vocabulary issue
anyway there's better ways better words
than
energy that's more more specific AR
culturally it's not acceptable to talk
in those
terms a different language to
communicate how would you communicate it
I would communicate about
uh immune processes in the body and the
viral process in the body things that
you can measure that are fairly
concrete if someone were to want to get
on a path of healing given that you've
researched so many different modalities
and have worked with so many patients um
and still do what's the path for them
what's their first few
steps I think the first
step is indeed to find language to
communicate what happens so the first
step is to find
somebody with whom you can talk about
your internal
experience and and begin to create some
internal order out of the chaos that
you're feeling right these things always
start off with u i get scared I get
angry and then you usually blame it and
other people say you make me angry you
make me scared so you try to try anybody
else at some point you become to realize
that there is something about me that
reacts in a particular way and I think
the first step is to find get language
for
yourself uh to
to
really be have somebody who helps you to
be honest with yourself which is very
hard to do yeah it's much easier to talk
about how awful that other person is
than how than your own
shortcomings so having a gentle guide
who really helps you to be honest and
helps you to find language for your
bodily reactions for your internal
experience is the first step and then
the next step is
um very very important part of the whole
step is uh learning to tolerate the
messages from your body and learning to
tolerate the feelings that you have and
one of the better pieces of research
I've done uh was on yoga and how
profoundly helpful yoga was for
traumatized people to have of course you
always measure the PTSD but it really
yoga if you're dedicated to it you get
it practice gives you a feeling of
ownership of your body in a way and I
think that's a good beginning step
owning yourself having language for
yourself understanding yourself and then
you look at what gets
stuck so uh certain images keep you
stuck or certain sounds or sensation you
go maybe EMDR is the right thing or
maybe you have a heart
you always feel scared you always feel
unable to concentrate then maybe new
feedback maybe the best thing that
really was what my book was about is I
could not give people a prescription of
what's best and when people ask me what
should I do I would say what did you
underline in my book that appeal to you
for example one of my favorite
treatments that I love practicing is pyr
drama where you get to have
experiences between you and other people
that are
novel uh but I would only do that if in
the chapter in the book about sa drama
really appeal to you and and the body
keeps score I don't have a psychedelic
chapter uh I just have a little sentence
paragraph about psychedelics like this
is cool we need to know more about it
now we have major chapter in in the new
book about psychedelics but again it has
more questions and
answers but happens right you open
another door and you know I I
interviewing Neil degrass Tyson many
years ago and he said basically you know
you you once you ask one more question
it sort of pushes the bubble out you
learn something it pushes this bubble
out of knowledge awareness questions it
just gets bigger and you have more of
everything like you're just expanding
and there's just more questions I you
say be distrustful of anybody who says
they have the answer for sure it's
always now I know a little bit but I
always say you know 40 years ago when I
started this we knew nothing now we know
a little bit and I like to say 40 years
from now I hope people are laughing at
what we're saying today because we have
to learn so much more evolving knowledge
yeah yeah yeah exactly well if there was
a question that you wouldd want answered
in your professional life what is that
question that you seek the most well I
think a very important question is how
can you get people to be curious about
themselves and own
reactions uh how we do we cultivate an
introspective culture where we really
feel ourselves as the core things we
need to work on is how I relate to my
environment basically and of course our
environment our world is culture is very
much not like that
you got to do that you got to get that
degree you got to do that and it's
not one of the things that I say quite
seriously in the hope that it will have
some impact is that I think every school
should teach kids the four hours Reading
Writing rithmetic and
self-regulation awareness every week
from gate through 12 you have classes in
how you calm yourself down how does it
work what do you feelings how do your
feelings work what happens in your brain
and you have practice of what it's like
to play basketball what does it do to
your body what it's like to sing
together what is it like to move
together what's like to do that and to
really get a very deep knowledge about
this creature who you are right now
schools focus on what's out there right
very important people should learn that
but people hopefully people also also
will learn about
themselves uh and of course what we see
in our culture is is our as our culture
is moving towards that there's strong
opposition and we go to ban books that
get us in touch with ourselves yeah
interesting it's a little bit of a
little little bit more conspiracy there
no but but that's that's the course of
human
history every time people get more
enlightened there's people who start
burning
people crucifying people you
know that's what humans are like
survival some other virus is not going
to survive if you wake up and start to
recognize your true power or what makes
you
unwell yeah and and so what what I'm
impressed with is that in the world I
live in uh people are very much
exploring things for themselves but when
I go to a doctor's office I'm always
impressed how the people around me are
all waiting for the doctor to tell them
what to
do how little authority most people have
about
themselves how little knowledge people
and how little curiosity often times
people have about
themselves I'll ask one more question
just because we're talking about
reflection a little bit about the brain
is there a strong role of the pineal
gland and in self-awareness and I can't
say that a thought that the pineal gland
was de seeded the soul right exactly
learned later that the penal gland
calcifies in most people by age 40 right
so the pineal gland doesn't show up much
in my literature searches H as is with
you it's the seed of the Soul right he
Liv
about
so is there any value in decalcifying
the pineal gland so that there is some
access to its function I think that
would be a leap I would not fund that
study no no so I should not use my
fluoride free toothpaste anymore and
worry about
that if that if you think that's good
for you you should definitely use it I
will not I should not pass a law that
you're not allowed to use your
toothpaste actually yeah well thank you
very much for your time I don't want to
don't want to overstay my welcome but uh
I was just super very very impressed
with this book and um thank you for
writing it and all the hard work and
good work you're doing thank you okay
thank you good
luck thanks everybody for listening to
the pretty intense podcast today I hope
you enjoyed it if you like what you
heard today and you want to hear more
please click on the Subscribe
button